[Music]
just as little is there present in
conscience that fluctuating uncertainty
of consciousness which now places
so-called pure morality outside of
itself into another wholly being and
takes itself to be unholy but then again
places so-called pure morality within
itself and the connection of the
sensuous with the moral in that other
being
6:36 is a very short paragraph it really
just could have been tacked on to the
end of 635 because it's not really
adding all that much but let's look at
it and see what what Hagel is
reinforcing here he says just as little
is there present in conscience
conscience is govision right that
fluctuating uncertainty of consciousness
and that uncertainty wouldn't give this
height so he's playing off of the this
term here a little bit of this in' right
knowledge knowing and he's saying there
isn't any such uncertainty here in
conscience which now places so-called
pure morality outside of itself into
another wholly being and takes itself to
be unholy but then again places
so-called pure morality within itself
and the connection of the sensuous with
the moral and that other being what do
we have there well we have another one
of the antinomies or contradictions that
came to light as the moral consciousness
was trying to make sense out of itself
and how it could possibly understand
fulfill embody morality right
and so that distinction between a holy
being in which morality somehow exists
and it's not us and we're like you know
these unworthy maggots compared to it
and the fact that that that morality
also exists in us and there isn't any
such beyond being that's just another
ant enemy to be overcome that's another
set of moments that Hegel would say have
to be incorporated into conscience and
in a certain way you could say that this
is one of the dangers actually of
conscience it makes us into that holy
being and it tells us that we're
definitely on the right track and the
action that we are choosing to do which
then transforms reality or produces a
new reality through the the action
through the actualization that you know
their vehicle
vier clickin of what it is that we're
choosing to do whatever interest
we're being motivated by and that's you
know that's reading a little bit more
into this passage but you know it makes
sense to do so and it helps to
contextualize why he's setting aside
this almost throwaway remark in this
this single paragraph
it renounces all these attitudes and
assemblance --is connected with the
moral view of the world when it
renounces that consciousness which
thinks of duty and reality as
contradictory according to this latter
view I act morally when I'm conscious of
performing only pure Duty and nothing
else but that this means in fact when I
do not act but when I really act I am
conscious of an other of a reality which
is already in existence and of a reality
I wish to produce I have a specific
purpose and fulfill a specific Duty in
which there is something else than the
pure duty which alone should be intended
conscience on the other hand is
awareness of the fact that when the
moral consciousness declares pure duty
to be the essence of its action this
pure purpose is ad assemblance of the
truth of the matter for the fact is that
pure Duty consists in the empty
abstraction of pure thought and has its
reality and its content only in a
specific reality in a reality which is
the reality of consciousness itself and
conscious does not as a mere thought
thing but as an individual as for
conscience itself this knows that it has
its truth in the immediate certainty of
itself this immediate concrete self
certainty is the essence of the action
looking at this certainty from the point
of view of the antithesis of
consciousness the content of the moral
action is the doers own immediate
individuality and the form of that
content is just this self as a pure
movement that is as the individuals
knowing or his own conviction
we have a far more substantive
discussion here in paragraph 637 which
reveals to us the contrast between
conscience which is going to be
something individual but allowing for
actual action actualizing action you
might say and that's on the one hand and
on the other hand the previous shapes of
the moral consciousness which wound up
foundering in a kind of mixed-up state
of dissemblers so here Hegel tells us
that that conscience renounces all these
attitudes all these stances and
assemblance --is connected with the
moral view of the world when it
renounces that consciousness which
thinks of duty and reality as
contradictory now is this just sort of
bootstrapping is this sort of you know
positive thinking you know you look at
things that appear to be contradictory
and you're like there's no contradiction
there or is this trying something out
actually seeing whether the
contradiction is there that you think is
there by acting so Hegel tells us
according to the latter view the
consciousness that thinks of duty and
reality is contradictory I act morally
when I am conscious of performing only
pure duty and nothing else than that and
then that means that you know I am moral
I am conscious of performing pure Duty
only when I do not act and that seems
paradoxical if not contradictory because
the whole point of having a duty is
you're supposed to do the duty right
it's something that you owe it's
something that you must fulfill and if
there's no concrete real vir CLE right
actual action hundl tots you know
however you want to frame it
in terms of the German terms that that
Hagel uses if you're not actually doing
something if you're not acting then how
the hell are you going to be moral so
you're kind of in a catch-22 if you act
you're immoral if you don't act
well you're not immoral but then you are
immoral hey so that's a problem
now Hegel points out when I really act I
am conscious now notice the term that he
brings in here of an other there's an
other who is haunting this just a few
paragraphs back I pointed out that this
is a section where Hegel is talking
about moral self-consciousness right and
self-consciousness always involves a
reference to an other so when I really
act and it is beautiful phrase right
here click handle right when I do any
action honden and I really do it I
actually do it I bring it into actuality
then what happens he says I'm conscious
of another of a vehicle a kite a reality
that is already in existence and I'm
also conscious of what's not yet there
but what I'm trying to bring about a
reality that I wish I choose I commit to
produce so we have an other who's not
yet a subjective other but at least
another that is not me is what it is
that I'm acting upon and I'm trying to
transform that into something else and
you know if you say well I really act IV
R click I actually act right is acting
in reality unreality through reality
transforming reality so if we think
about this in terms of duty he says this
means that I have a specific Duty
something that is actually conditioned
that that exists as a requirement for me
in the world that I could fulfill a
specific duty
I have a specific purpose and fulfill a
specific duty in which there is
something else other than the pure duty
which should be intended and at that
point the moral self-consciousness would
say aha see you are self-interested you
are doing something conditioned by your
inclinations your desires your wish for
happiness your determination to make the
world look like what you want it to look
like and conscience would say yeah damn
right I am
because what you have to offer me over
here on the other side is empty abstract
there's no purchase here and I do have
to have something that I can actually
make real so he goes on and he says
conscience is awareness of the fact that
when the moral consciousness declares
pure duty to be the essence of its
action now I'm going to stop there for a
second and just repeat that conscience
is awareness of the fact that when the
moral consciousness declares pure duty
to be the essence of its action and we
could end that sentence by saying moral
consciousness is lying to itself and
lying to conscience and lying to the
subject of it it's trying to pass
something off as not being the case
mainly what conscience is actually
bringing to the table and it's trying to
present a false case to us so it says
this pure purpose is a decembe once of
the truth of the matter a you know you
said well what does the decembe lence of
the truth isn't that kind of a play on
Azzam you knowed assemblance by itself
is already non truth isn't it well yes
but what is dissemblers the semblance
fear Stellan right is when you are
putting something you know you're not
just like totally lying you're putting
something in place of the truth as the
truth and you're blocking the path to
the truth in this case the truth of
action that conscience
makes possible moral action not just
action like I'm waving my hands action
that is genuinely meaningful for human
beings and is right or good or what we
ought to do so he goes on and he says
how do we know this the fact is pure
duty consists in the empty abstraction
of pure thought it has its reality and
its content only in a specific reality a
reality which is the reality of
consciousness itself so this is a key
part of the decembe once we project out
there this this pure duty or purpose but
a duty or purpose can only genuinely
exist in a conscious being and that
conscious beings relation to other
things including other conscious beings
or we can say the totality of the
universe or whatever but you don't get
moral consciousness without having a
consciousness and that means an
individuality you can say of course we
share a consciousness in general of
moral truths right we can talk in
language back and forth about what's
right and what's wrong or what's good or
bad yes there is a kind of interest
subjectivity there yes there is an
objectivity there but if I'm going to do
something I have to do it if you're
gonna do something you have to do it if
somebody's going to do something and I
think back to all these these you know
problems where everybody just kind of
looks at each other like you know who's
gonna act everybody stands around and
does nothing until we can actually say
listen I'm gonna be the one to do
something nobody will act if we wait
around for you know pure consciousness
to find its pure duty motivated by its
pure purpose then nothing is ever going
to happen except for us sitting around
jibber jabbering about that right so
conscience allows us a way past this
seeming Perea so he says we have a
reality which is the reality of
consciousness itself consciousness not
as a mere
thing but as an individual as for
conscience itself he says this knows
that it has its truth in it the
immediate certainty of itself so we have
conscience and we have self certainty
right and this is where so often right
the Hegelian dialectic picks itself up
because once we have self certainty
start looking for truth and start
looking for the discord between the two
of them we're not we're not there yet
but that's gonna start happening soon
isn't it so he says it knows it as its
truth in the immediate certainty of
itself this immediate concrete self
certainty I know who I am and what I'm
doing even if I can't you know give you
a complete narrative or tell you
everything about myself and sometimes a
little you know I'm a little confused
about what exactly I'm doing or whether
it's right or wrong but I can at least
have the feeling of self certainty that
I'm doing the right thing that I'm
fulfilling a duty a specific duty with a
specific purpose and I can say yes it is
specific but that's okay because it has
to be because I'm an individual so Hegel
goes on and he says this is the essence
of the action looking at this certainty
from the point of view of the antithesis
of consciousness the content of the
moral action is the doers own immediate
individuality and the form of that
content is just the self as a pure
movement as the individuals knowing or
as his own conviction his own being
convinced a bird's-eye Gong of what it
is that he is doing so the content of
the moral action is the doer zone
immediately individuality which they are
using to change things the form of that
is the self as a pure movement it's what
they know and you notice that Hegel
speaks in very cognitive terms about the
action that we're engaging in but he's
quite right when we do things generally
we're aware of doing them and if we want
to say that we're doing the right thing
we really ought to be able to identify
the action
that were engaged in and that is a
knowing of that action is it not
looking more closely at the unity of the
moral consciousness and at the
significance of its moments we see that
it regards itself as the in itself or
essence but as conscience it apprehends
it's being for self or itself the
contradiction of the moral consciousness
resolves itself that is the difference
which lies at its base proves to be none
and it runs away into pure net
negativity but this precisely is the
self a simple self which is both appear
knowing and a knowledge of itself is
this individual consciousness
consequently this self constitutes the
content of what was previously the empty
essence for it is actual a self which no
longer has the significance of being a
nature alien to the essence and with
laws of its own independent of it as the
negative it is the difference within
pure essence a content and one to which
is valid in and for itself
638 is really just running over the same
ground as the previous paragraphs but it
does reinforce what is being brought out
about conscience and about the
importance of individuality concrete
individuals in this section so Hegel
begins by saying looking more closely at
the unity of the moral consciousness and
at the significance of meaning of its
moments which it's finally recognizing
as moments right we see that it regards
itself as the in itself the on Zeke or
as essence as Bazin so it does grasp
itself in some sense right the
individual is able to make sense out of
themselves as moral consciousness but
it's a contradictory consciousness
because they're these these moments are
never really brought together in any
sort of full unity and it's got its own
self sort of dragging behind that it
asked well how does this fit into these
contradictory moments we saw that
decembe lense is not going to get it out
get itself out of that conscience offers
us a different path to tread so he says
as conscience this moral consciousness
is now transformed we have a new gestalt
as we pointed out right when new shape
of consciousness a new shape of moral
consciousness a new shape of morality as
something that is conscious of itself
conscious of itself in the individual in
the conscience and he says that it
apprehends it's being for self or self
notice that he doesn't say it grasps
that you know itself as for itself he
talks about it actually grasps its
physique sign so he's actually saying
its fruisé eek for itself he's saying
that it has being for itself and that it
is able to apprehend that being for
itself yeah
it's own self as it's helped right no
longer as a vision but as a self it has
a picture of who it is it understands
itself in certain ways this is not you
know radically new we've had spirit
self-consciousness taking all these
stances on whoa who the hell am I
I'm the noble consciousness I'm the
person who follows the law of the heart
I'm the person who is engaging in
observing reason I'm the master I'm the
slave I'm the stoic I'm this I'm mad I'm
this I'm that
right at this point in time it's taking
up a individuality that has its own
content not supplied by any of those
previous shapes and it's turning to the
world and saying I'm gonna do some
things I'm going to choose which path I
take and I'm certain of it so he goes on
and he says the contradiction of the
moral consciousness we're returning back
now to the earlier moral consciousness
resolves itself it dissolves itself
right alpha loosen the difference which
lies at its base proves to be none
what's the difference that lies at its
base between all these different sides
of the antinomy like between happiness
and morality or between nature and duty
or between you know a holy will and my
actual will that morality has to be and
we could go on and on and on all of
these turn out at this point in time to
be differences that aren't really
differences that don't make a difference
why not there's really two reasons one
is they lead us into these crazy
antinomies that you know leave us unable
to figure out what morality actually is
and how we comport ourselves in relation
to it how we act but also because it
produces the sort of paralysis which is
again you know one of those antinomies I
can't act if I do I'm immoral but if I
don't act I'm immoral how the hell am I
going to be moral I have to be moral
right it's like an endless you know
crazy talk running through
one's head and that can't be where
spirit ends if it is then we could end
the book right here and say well you
know we did all this progression we got
to the morality and morality as these
antinomies and they're crazy and if we
try to live them out we'll go crazy and
then you know we wind up with
interesting readings that you know would
be like a certain caricature if
post-structuralism wouldn't wouldn't
they right
let's go back to the Hegel though so he
says the contradiction of moral
consciousness resolves itself the
difference proves to be none it runs
away into pure negativity now pure
negativity is not necessarily a bad
thing for Hegel pure negativity is also
a capacity to sort of wrap itself around
anything pure negativity is openness
pure negativity is the self which can
take in all these things that it is not
this is not anything new right we talked
about this way way back in the
consciousness and self-consciousness
section so a pure negativity it's a
simple self he says which is both a pure
knowing and a knowledge of itself as
this individual consciousness a viscid
right guv this and conscience is coming
from this and I know who I am I know
what I need to do I know what I'm going
to do and I know what I'm going to do it
in and what I'm going to transform and I
know it in part because it's a task
ahead of me and now I know it as I'm
doing it and now I know the result
because I'm the one who brought about
the results right so there's this
relation of knowledge there he goes and
he says this self constitutes the
content in halts something that that's
actually there of what was previously
the empty essence the empty vase and
because it's actual it's via klieg it
has a place in the world I've done
something I accomplished a deed or a
duty so he says it's a self which no
longer has the significance of being a
nature alien to the assam
and with laws of its own independent of
it why as the negative it's the
difference within pure essence a Content
and one too which is valid in and for
itself which which has validity both on
Zeke and FERS II so at this point things
look pretty good don't they
we're sounding like conscience is really
the way out of all of these crazy
antinomies of morality that we ploughed
our way through in the two previous
sections we still have a bit more
development yet to go in this notion of
conscience you know you could say we're
climbing the hill and then we're gonna
get a good look and see whether things
turn out to be quite so rosalie
optimistic as Hegel's making them out to
be at this point but we're actually
moving quite well through this we've
gone from the moral consciousness now to
an individual conscience that we could
all identify with right
I'm conscience your conscience and so is
that person down the street the only
question is are we true to ourselves as
conscience or can that question even
arise at this state of self certainty
and remember there's a dialectic and
Hegel constantly between self certainty
this self assertion and then something
beyond that that would be truth
you